returning now to our top story in
China's Parliament has this our approved
national security laws that bypass Hong
Kong's legislature let's bring in
Katrina you in Beijing for us so Katrina
as expected the National People's
Congress has approved plans for a
controversial security law for Hong Kong
what details do we know now about this
law is it going to be as draconian as
Hong Kong citizens fear will be that's
rightfully well we still have to wait on
more details all we know as yet is that
moments ago China's National People's
Congress voted to pass this law there
were 2885 votes in total and
unsurprisingly the the vote was
overwhelmingly a yes with two thousand
eight hundred and seventy eight people
voting yes one person voting no and six
abstaining from the vote now this is not
surprising this Congress is widely known
as a parliament where many of these
policies have already been pre-approved
and pre discussed it's really just a way
of rubber stamping and announcing these
policies to the world we expect to hear
more details about this law over the
next few days no doubt and perhaps from
Premier Li Keqiang when he speaks over
the next hour at the closing of the
National People's Congress and we do
know that Beijing is perhaps bracing
itself an international response to this
security law the u.s. of course has
threatened to to change Hong Kong's
trading status and also bring this issue
to the UN Security Council as a
deterrent well it seems those about that
both of those deterrence has had no
effect on Beijing's decision Thank You
Katrina for nagarjuna you live for us
there in Beijing